let's go next to our caller from the
4:05 area code who's calling today from
4:05 uh yes this is stone hey stone
what's up hey David so to kind of set up
my question
nowadays we have just incredible
technology you know we have the
technology to provide clean energy
renewable energy you know create clean
water vertical farms 3d print at homes
things of that nature and it seems like
the problem is that programs like this
never pick up or expand because they are
not profitable how do we change people's
mindset so they are willing to buy in
towards programs that would help them
but they only ever see that initial cost
I don't know that I agree that they're
not profitable
they're just profitable for different
people let me give you some examples and
a lot of this is speculative and we're
just not going to know for a few years
so vertical farming for example huge
promise but what's the advantage to
vertical farming vertical farming can be
done in a vertical space often inside of
a building including in urban centers if
you're a farmer in the Midwest vertical
farming is not profitable for you
because you're in the Midwest with huge
fields not in an urban area with a
building where you would actually do it
so vertical farming is profitable for
different people than normal farming is
profitable for another example that you
mentioned 3d printing homes 3d printing
homes the technology it's still early in
that technology I mean you know we've
seen modular become more of a thing but
3d printing is different the people who
would benefit from 3d printing homes are
not the people who concur
we control the building industry and big
builders and and contractors so it's not
that it's economically not viable to 3d
print homes although it's still
expensive today because we've not scaled
yet but the people who would benefit
from it are different than the ones who
currently control that industry so I
just think that what your net your
assessment is right that there are
misaligned incentives but it's not that
it's just not profitable to go in these
new directions is that it's going to be
profitable for different people than the
ones that currently control those
industries okay I guess kind of a short
follow-up question I mean if if we you
know we have the power to end
homelessness and end hunger and we we
have the technology to do it so so why
doesn't it happen lack of political will
and that we've talked about a lot
there's a lack of political will always
having another election around the
corner is a disincentive to deal with
some of these bigger picture issues that
we can solve except that there's not
really the political will to do it that
that's a systemic problem which which
I've talked about many times before
stone thank you for the phone call I
really appreciate hearing from you thank
you all right we'll take a quick break
if you are holding don't hang up because
we will go right back to the phones
after this short break